- Quelques points
d'éclaircissement avec Maître
Guylaine Bachandne Bachand que s
entendez à Isabelle Richer,
ma collègue, régulièrement.
Maître Bachand, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir, Monsieur Roy.
-  Je le disais, pour nous,
c'est étranger que des jurys
soient dans un procès civil,
ça n'existe pas au Canada,
n'est-ce pas?
- Non, ça n'existe pas
au civil... le soir, ils
rentraient chez eux. Nous,
on a des jurys dans les affaires
criminelles qui sont séquestrés,
pendant le délibéré, on est
vraiment dans un autre univers.
- Bon, est-ce qu'il y a des
possibilités d'appel maintenant?
- Oui, c'est sûr que je pense
entre autres à Madame Heard
qui pourrait porter en appel.
Lui, ce qu'il plaidait en trois
points, rapidement, c'est
qu'elle avait tout inventé.
Que, dans le fond, le premier
amendement qui est la liberté
d'expression, ça ne s'applique
pas aux menteurs. Et il disait
même, excusez-moi, ce n'est pas
très élégant comme argument,
mais il disait : "Elle a tout
inventé, elle est malicieuse."
parce que c'est bon dans le
système de Hollywood, les
producteurs, ils engagent
des gens de #Metoo.
Alors, je pense que... elle
qui entre autres plaidait...
bon... que ça s'était passé
mais qu'il y a aussi tout
un message à envoyer voulait
aux femmes qu'il faut toujours
plus de preuves, 102 photos, 42
films, ça ne serait pas
suffisant... ça pourrait
être un motif qu'elle souhaite
appeler.
- Mais contrairement à un procès
ici où le doute
raisonnable rend non coupable
quelqu'un, là, c'est
ndérance des preuves...
autrement dit qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment cru la version de
Madame Heard, mais ils n'avaient
pas besoin d'être 100 %
convaincus qu'elle mentait.
C'était plus probable qu'elle
mentait, c'est un peu ça l'idée?
- Tout à fait. D'ailleurs, c'est
pour ça, il a magasiné son État,
il était en VirYz+
parce qu'il y a ce fardeau
de preuve-là, il avait perdu
en Angleterre parce que c'était
un espèce de hors de tout doute
même au civil. Mais, donc, c'est
un fardeau qui était quand même
plus facile, si on peut dire,
pour M. Depp.
- Donc les jurés n'ont pas cru
qu'elle avait été battue et
victime de violences conjugales,
et par conséquent, quand elle
écrit cette lettre dans le
Washington Post ou
dénonce comme victime, elle dit
il faut que les femmes ça
que ça doit cesser, elle
dit que c'est de la diffamation
parce qu'il n'y a pas de
substance?
- C'est la même chose ici au
Québec un procès en diffamation,
on ne parle pas de ça dans les
airs il faut ensuite regarder...
c'est l'histoire d'un couple
toxique et la violence conjugale
ce qui m'a étonné c'est que non
seulement elle est responsable
dans la lettre ouverte, elle
diffamé en disant qu'elle avait
vécu cette expérience, mais elle
est maintenue responsable de
diffamation pour le titre du
journal. Vous savait dans votre
d=++O+
tou9 les titres, mais elle avait
retweeté. Ça aussi ça peut être.
- Est-ce que c'est une victoire
totale pour Monsieur Depp parce
qu'il doit lui aussi contenu
claration d'un de ses
avocats qui accusaient Madame
Heard que c'était un coup monté,
llions, alors
est-ce que c'est une victoir
départager pour une nette
victoire?
- c'est une nette victoire pour
lui. L'avocat dit qu'elle a
appelé le policier qui sont
partis pas contents de sa, elle
a pris du vin et en amis un peu,
cette phrase, ça n'avait pas du
tout prouvé dans le procès.
C'est minime par rapport à toute
l'histoire.- Donc, nette victoir
Johnny Depp qu'est-ce que vous
pensez en terminant on le voit
sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
des camps et déjà ça s'engueule,
les gens qui disent que c'est un
recul pour le mouvement Metoo,
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça?
- Je trouvais que l'avocat était
vraiment convaincant là-dessus
en disant qu'est-ce que ça va
prendre de plus? Une photo de
plus, rendez-vous médical de
plu9-